(upbeat music)
(bell ringing)
- Today we're going to pose
like high fashion models
for the first time.
(wind swooshing)
- High fashion modeling looks hard,
looks very uncomfortable poses.
- I'm an avid watcher
of Victoria Secret Fashion Show.
That's the extent of my runway knowledge.
- Is that high fashion?
- Sure is, Kane.
- Really interested in the
artistic element to it.
Where it feels a little
more, like, elevated.
- It could be a girl laying on the floor
and you can barely see the outfit,
but it's high fashion.
- I know that everyone's probably wearing
very expensive clothing.
- Couture, I believe, is what it's called.
- They range between naked in a hot tub
with, like, a necklace
or a high end apartment.
- They're all skinny.
Everyone has crazy bone structure
and jaw lines in high fashion.
I don't really have that at all.
- Being confident,
giving a smoldering look.
(cat meowing)
- They just look like they don't have
a care in the world.
They're just like...
- It looks so effortless.
(upbeat music)
- I'm excited to see, like, what I learn
from the photographers and
how well I take direction.
- I'm gonna look like I'm
farting most of the time.
(mimics farting)
- Who knows, maybe, we're
gonna have an anxiety attack.
- You're gonna kill it.
(suspenseful music)
- Hoping that stepping
outside my comfort zone
will maybe open up new
opportunities to looking cool.
- We have great photographers.
We have great makeup artist here today
that are gonna, hopefully, help us along.
- My name is Brandon Sosa.
- I'm Arthur Galvao.
Our concept today, we're getting you guys
in a campaign and fashion
brand environment.
- [Brandon] The first set is
kind of inspired by Gucci.
- Patterns, a lot of colors.
- Lots of props, busy living room vibe.
And the other set's going
to be a simple red backdrop.
Very poppy but a bit more minimal.
I'm sure there will be
a few challenges today.
Sometimes there's preconceived notions
on how you're suppose
to behave as a model.
The learning lesson today
will be that less is more.
(upbeat music)
- The makeup was a lot crazier than usual,
just 'cause it's suppose
to be high fashion.
Our faces are a lot more mannequin like
'cause it's suppose to be sleek.
You're supposed to not look real, almost.
- Something I've never experienced before,
living the life of high end.
- I couldn't get a babysitter for Marty.
He came along and we just
incorporated him in the shoot.
(playful music)
- I don't think I did any smiling photos
because that's more commercial.
The whole time I was just like,
alright, who the fuck am I looking at?
Alright, who's this bitch?
Okay, yeah.
- I felt like my face, it can look bored,
and so a lot of times when I look up,
- The whole time my face
was just saying play dead.
That was my thought process.
- I feel very self conscious.
I have really bad teeth growing up
so I've never been as comfortable smiling.
So it was really nice in these
because I just got to
be like dead in the eyes
which is my natural go-to, anyways.
High fashion's dead
inside, dead in the eyes.
- The photographer asked
me, like, give me attitude.
I was like, no, like.
- He was like give me attitude.
So you're like okay and
just walked off the set.
I think I'm more comfortable
with commercial photography,
where you're holding
something and you're like...
(laughing)
(intense music)
- I think the hardest part of the day
was just what to do with my hands.
- Every little movement matters.
Questioning like, oh my god,
I closed my hand, like
do I look over there?
They were like look more masculine.
I'm like okay but when you're normally
sitting in a chair, you're not like,
do I look masculine, you just sit.
It was a little bit of a struggle.
Sitting positions, I
always question myself.
If I'm gonna look slouchy
or, like, my legs are gonna look weird.
- Unconventional poses.
One foot on the couch.
One foot touching the floor
while I'm holding my suit jacket.
Everything was, like, what.
- It made me second guess
all my posing skills.
You feel like your leg
was in the right place
but then it comes off weird on camera
so they knew exactly where to put us.
- Sosa had to tweak me and move me
exactly where they wanted me
until they found the right position.
(funky music)
- When I first started, I
was a little bit nervous
and then once we got
those first few shots off,
I got much more relaxed
and just felt way more comfortable
I was able to just give a natural feel.
Now I know I can do this
or this or even this.
- You killed it, in the red set.
You were just like bam, bam, bam,
bam, bam, bam, bam.
- Yeah, that's just cause they showed
me what to do and I was just like,
okay I can do that.
- He just kinda moved me in a spot
and I felt like I couldn't move
and then I saw Jeremy like kill it
so I wanted to relax more.
- Poses felt much more rigid and defined,
which I really enjoyed.
They were a lot more dramatic.
- With all these poses,
you feel a little bizarre and awkward
but then you see the photo
and you're like, damn.
(upbeat electronic music)
- The group shot was crazy.
It totally looked like we just stepped
out of a Gucci ad, so like sick.
- Pose be at its candid.
Initially he said,
"So-and-so look at so-and-so"
and we're looking at each other
we couldn't stop laughing.
It's kinda awkward, you're just
staring at the other person
across from you.
- It felt awkward but
when you saw the photo it didn't look like
you were looking at the person.
They were very good at communication.
Sometimes photographers
will just kind of shoot
and then you're like oh,
do I look good, okay.
They're taking pictures,
but it totally like x-ed out
what I was worried about.
- The composition in the
pictures was really great
and you could just tell
they put a lot of time
and effort into the way they posed you
and the way they shot
it, it was really neat.
(wind swooshing)
(soft music)
- I was like, you know what,
I've spent 26 years being inside my head
and being insecure.
This new year, I've finally decided
to just own who the fuck you are,
have fun with this, and
play, mother fucker.
- I had no idea what to expect
when we started shooting these.
I don't necessarily picture myself
as a beautiful person,
but when I saw these photos,
it just came out so good.
Beyond my wildest imagination.
I'm going out to the store
and buying a navy tux today, I'm obsessed.
- I felt really special.
Beautiful, I felt like over the top.
I'm just like don't talk
to me right now, I'm busy.
- It actually turned out a lot better
than I thought it would
for like my own photos
'cause I recently just shaved my head
and I'm still like
kinda insecure about it.
Seeing these cool photos,
with my bald head now,
it makes me more
comfortable about it, too.
- I enjoyed it.
They were so good at their job.
I feel like my self esteem
went up a small rung.
I might learn to love myself down the road
but not after today.
- Do you feel less trash?
- Less trash?
- Doing this I was
like, yep, I'm up there.
I'm definitely still trash
but I'm like an elevated trash bag
that can hold anything you put in it.
- Growing up I was probably a little bit
intimidated by how men
are perceived in the media
and how men's bodies look
and I compared that to myself a lot.
To be able to own who I am
and be happy and confident with my body,
that was really rewarding
because I proved to myself
that you don't have to look like Hercules
to experience something as amazing
as high fashion photography.
I'm so used to kind of watching
and looking behind the scenes
so it was really fun for me to kind of
have the opportunity to
be in front of the camera
and have fun and have some photos
that I'm gonna cherish
for the rest of my life
and hopefully someone else
will cherish them too.
I'm still waiting.
It was really fun for us.
We've been doing a lot
of projects together.
This was the first time we really
were all put in front of the camera
at the same time and it was really fun
to get to kinda like laugh
and also try new things
with everyone right there.
- [Man] You did slay.
- [Man] We all did. It
just looks very crisp.
- Yeah I love how we
all posed individually,
but overall we're all connected.
We're not just like holding each other
or like, you know,
just like everyone doing their own thing
but we, magically, look
like we're together.
- I would totally do this again.
I 1,000% have a new profile pic.
I can't wait to post it
and see these likes roll in.
- I would definitely try this again
'cause now that I have bit of experience
I think it would be a lot
easier the second time.
Marty was a better high
fashion model than I.
(laughing)
- He's better than all of us, actually.
- With the right team, the sound stage,
professional photographer,
the hair and makeup,
wardrobe and all that.
- You can all look good,
everyone can look...
(upbeat rock music)
Maybe.
(wind swooshing)
(hinge squeaking)